and michael called me and said
that he was gonna call off this wedding
and that he was going to
give her money to go back to ukraine and
buy her a plane ticket
do you want me to go home
i said i don't listen to you i called
you she you said your mom you want me to
go home no
i adoption mike
say something he was at a loss for words
after his mom claimed that he was
preparing to send natalie home
before he actually called off the
wedding
of course mike denied that i had no
intentions of sending you home
but now the question is is his mom lying
or is he
this timeline is just a little uh
confusing yes
i still don't get it in addition to that
not adding up
his mom also admitted to calling tamra
the night before the wedding
to ask her to object during the ceremony
damn some of the other 90 day cast
members thought she was so wrong for
doing that
but was she really i have my opinions
which we'll get to
in just a few plus i will not let him
control me ever again andrew and his
luscious hair
made a dramatic exit after producers
told him that amira
will only tell her side of the story if
she doesn't have to see or talk to him
this is unfair and i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna accept this
this style here speaking of unfair yara
was brought to tears
after she had to watch jovi's strip club
bachelor party
in front of everyone for the first time
damn mike i thought you all had a bag
this was part one of the season eight
tell all let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio
you know what's interesting about these
tell-alls
is that you realize how many couples
don't actually watch the show
which i guess is understandable it's a
way to distance yourself from all the
pressures and opinions
a private dance in a strip club in
america is not that big of a deal i
personally
will want to be emotionally prepared
it's a lot as we're about to see
all right mike and natalie these two
arrived at the tell-all
separately and mad at one another
shocker when they were asked why here's
what they had to say
you know each other or not i mean like
why you come separate guys i don't know
why you can't separate mike
um
uh we just came in and uh yeah we got
two separates here
mike we've seen you and natalie at your
worst
don't hold back now
here we go even though they were mad at
each other or should i say natalie was
mad at mike
once they got on set it seemed as if
they made some sort of pack
before they arrived to not speak on
certain things
because when sean would ask mike a
question natalie would give him this
death stare like you better remember
what we talked about but after the
season they just had
i don't think being quiet is going to
make a difference
natalie when you arrived at the studio
this morning
you seemed like you were a little upset
what was bothering you
um was there any you know
conflict between you and mike that that
contributed to how you were feeling this
morning
no natalie why did you and mike
arrive separately to the studio this
morning i'm not dancing
you don't want to answer why don't you
want to answer
because i don't oh okay
natalie by the way she wasn't wearing
her ring
she said she left it at home because she
didn't want it to get stolen
you be the judge on whether you think
she's telling the truth or not
let's go ahead and get into their
wedding drama
they replay eclipse from the day before
mike and natalie's original wedding date
and the day mike called off the wedding
natalie didn't watch the episode
so of course seeing it for the first
time had her in tears
mike went on to explain that the night
before their wedding
he started to feel lost i was just
feeling lost so he left the house in the
middle of the
night to go down the street to some lake
where there was
no phone service to try to find some
peace of mind
when natalie couldn't find him she
assumed
the worst she thought he went out to
cheat on her before their wedding
now if you don't think this situation
can get any messier
enters mike's mom who made it seem like
mike's decision
to call off the wedding to natalie was
premeditated
and not the cold feet last minute
decision as he described
and michael called me and said
that he was going to call off this
wedding and that he was going to
give her money to go back to ukraine and
buy her a plane ticket a dozen
i had no intentions of sending you home
i know but mike that's what your mom
just said
she said you talked and you said you
were gonna call up the wedding and give
her money to go back to ukraine that was
after she'd left we talked it wasn't
before
it was just days before the wedding when
he told me that
it should not be this hard to understand
the story
why is it so confusing i don't know if
this is a situation where his mom
thinks she's in the loop with their
relationship but she's really not
and she's getting the dates mixed up if
that is the case
mike didn't do a good job at explaining
what really happened
which just makes it suspicious
i said i don't listen i called you she
said your mom you want me to go home
no speak now or forever hold your peace
might
let's talk about the fact that his mom
did admit to calling tamra
the night before their wedding to tell
her to stand up and object
during the ceremony that's a lot of
responsibility to put on someone else
they get married it seemed like mike was
very happy on his wedding day
so do you still wish they had not gotten
married when she comes here and she
wants to change everything about him and
change his lifestyle and change
who he is and what he does and
everything else i i'm not real
thrilled with that because he's an adult
and he can make his own decisions
i agree with you yeah you're his mother
if it was your child and you seen your
child being treated
badly and whatnot wouldn't you
not be happy i have three grown children
i have a son i would never
do that hold up hold up
okay i love rebecca but i don't think
she has any room to chime in on this
her kids had to step into parent mode
when it came to her situation
they didn't necessarily treat her like
an adult and it was because
they were worried they might not have
objected to her wedding
but they followed her to the airport and
confessed to putting zied
through a number of tests luckily
rebecca and ziad's situation got better
but mike and natalie
their relationship is still toxic so
while i get the fact
that mike's a grown man and his mom
shouldn't have asked tamra to object
i also understand that a mother will go
to extreme lengths
to protect her child grown or not
so next time maybe mike shouldn't call
his mommy
when things hit the fan with natalie and
get her involved then they won't have
this
issue oh my god
ain't good after all this went down
natalie gave mike the silent treatment
during their lunch break
[Music]
that was a high school flashback moment
wow
definitely alright let's switch gears
and quickly take a look
at yara's reaction after she watched a
clip where jovi went upstairs in the
strip club
and got a private dance from a stripper
once again
this is her first time watching it i
don't know how she didn't hear about it
or why jovi didn't even warn her that
this might pop
up but let's take a look
[Music]
it makes me really mad like i don't
think it's respectful to me
as your woman to put somebody to put a
stripper on you and sit and talk talking
and hugging her it's unrespectful to me
why would you put some woman to your
knees when you have a
woman waiting for you at home but he is
a girl ass man and i can't tell him what
to do
like why should they scream on him
should they yell should they should they
do what being a psycho for he doesn't go
there
girl yes all of the above
no i'm just joking well kind of
i will say this jovi is a lucky man to
have found yara
because not that many women will take
all of what he comes with
oh my goodness i was not prepared for
this jovi's mom
also reacted to her son's behavior by
saying that she was disappointed
and she wished she could just shake him
so gwen is there anything that you want
to say to your son
right now i probably can't say
on tv oh gwen
all right lastly andrew walks out of the
tell-all after amira
refuses to have contact with him so
to respect amir's request which is to
not
face you to not be in direct contact
with you
we have to do these separately so we're
gonna have to ask you to leave
for the segment but that makes no sense
because this is a tell-all and we're
talking about the story
and we're going through the graveyard of
it and i think we kind of have to do
that in the same room
just don't show me on the camera we have
to respect
her wishes on that i'm just gonna go
home i'm not a huge fan of andrew and
amira's situation
but i get why he was upset he said that
facing her
was the reason why he came to the telaul
in the first place
and everyone is having tough
conversations so why can't they
but according to amira her anxiety won't
allow it
next week we hear straight from her plus
we hear from tariq
hazel and their ex-girlfriend minty
i'm gonna have a panic attack damn
oh oh i would never call her a liar but
the story seems bogus to me
i think they're both lying if she have
girlfriend this military have two
girlfriends
they're all three have sex all right
togezer three have sex
minty and hazel has there been intimacy
between the two of you
i'm never going to do that i don't know
why so am i lying now
so let me explain all right 90 day fans
fam
make sure you stick with e.t because as
usual we are covering it all
i'll see you next time